. If there's anybody approximating a kingmaker
remaining in the Republican Party, to some
degree, it is actually a 78 year old Republican
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell, and
love him or hate him.
And I don't like the guy.
He has been one of the most effective Republicans
in the last decade at just getting things
done when Republicans want to do something
and blocking Democrats from doing things,
when Republicans don't want them doing things.
The Merrick Garland Supreme Court nomination
certainly comes to mind.
And immediately following Joe Biden's formal
Electoral Electoral College win on Monday,
where each state's electors voted and confirmed
that indeed Joe Biden has 270 electoral votes.
Mitch McConnell acknowledged Joe Biden's win
and congratulated Joe Biden.
Now, this is not praise of Mitch McConnell.
Mitch McConnell avoided acknowledging that
Joe Biden won for five weeks after the election,
even when it was obvious that Joe Biden had
won.
This is not about Mitch McConnell being a
good guy.
It's once again, even someone as horrible
as Mitch McConnell, as unwilling to admit
what is there and plain to see.
As Mitch McConnell is saying, Joe Biden won,
effectively ending any remote possibility
that the Republican Party would insist that
Joe Biden didn't really win.
Here is Mitch McConnell yesterday on the floor
of the U.S. Senate.
Take a listen.
But our system of government has processes
to determine who will be sworn in on January
the 20th.
The Electoral College has spoken.
So today, I want to congratulate President
elect Joe Biden, the president elect is no
stranger to the Senate.
He's devoted himself to public service for
many years.
I also want to congratulate the vice president
elect, our colleague from California, Senator
Harish.
Beyond our differences, all Americans can
take pride that our nation has a female vice
president elect for the very first time.
I look forward to finishing out the next thirty
six days strong with President Trump.
Our nation needs us to add another bipartisan
chapter to this record of achievement.
So this is important for a few reasons.
Number one, this signals that there's really
nothing left for Trump.
I mean, truly nothing to try to steal this
election.
Now, I know that the Kuhnen people and the
cultists and even Trump himself and you know,
Kayleigh McEnany, as we saw earlier, they're
going to continue acting as if there's more
to do.
Maybe Janet Ellis is going to if she's recovered
from coronavirus, they're going to keep going.
But when even the Senate majority leader on
January 6th, who do you think is going to
interfere with Joe Biden officially being
president elect in terms of Congress accepting
the votes?
It would be members of the Republican Party
in the House and Senate.
And the Senate majority leader here has said
congratulations to Joe Biden.
So it signals the emptying of the bag of tricks,
so to speak.
But secondly, this is also relevant and important
for people who were dreaming of something
to happen sometime between now and the inauguration
that would slow down or prevent Joe Biden
swearing in.
When Mitch McConnell acknowledges the president
elect, it really makes that dream or really
it's a nightmare.
It makes it all but an impossibility.
And we also learned that Mitch McConnell and
Joe Biden spoke after this.
Congratulations.
Here's Joe Biden briefly speaking to the media
yesterday, telling us how that call with Mitch
McConnell went.
I had a good conversation with.
And so I called him to thank him for the congratulations
on the whole, we disagree on a lot of things.
I think we can work together on Iraq, but
certainly not on one another.
And we agreed we'd get together sooner than
later.
And I'm looking forward to working with him.
Just want to know, I spoke with and calling
other members.
I spoke with some other members, as well as
about a dozen calling.
And as I pick them up, I'll tell you who I've
spoken to will say thank you.
So that's straightforward.
And to the point they're so slowly but surely,
all of the remaining I's are dotted and T's
are crossed to nobody's surprise, except for
the millions of Trump cultists who thought
that this might go some other way.
Now, my only concern about what Joe Biden
said continues to be the same one I've had
from before the election.
I hope that Joe Biden is merely paying lip
service to the idea of getting things done
with Mitch McConnell, because it would be
cartoonishly naive to think that this Republican
Party is going to work with you on anything.
And as I've said before, the only way you
would get this Republican Party to work with
you on anything, there's there's two scenarios
in which this Republican Party might help
you.
One is if they determined that getting in
the way of what you're working on would actually
hurt them electorally.
Like if you if they determine, imagine that
there's no stimulus passed now and Biden gets
to oversee a second stimulus.
If Republicans determine that not doing a
second stimulus is bad for them, they might
actually come to the table with Joe Biden,
but they would still try to make it mostly
for corporations and not really for four individuals.
The second scenario where Republicans would
work with Joe Biden or work with Democrats
in general is if Joe Biden and Democrats are
willing to accept such outrageous compromise
to get Republicans on board, then it becomes
almost like a Pyrrhic victory, where it's
a victory on paper.
But you may actually be doing more harm than
good in so working with these Republicans.
So my concern continues to be the naiveté.
If Joe Biden really thinks he's going to work
with these people, he's not.
Now, very quickly, Mitch McConnell became
enemy number one of the Trump cult.
Will do more about this later.
But just one example for you here.
This is a video clip of Trump sycophant Charlie
Kirk actually saying that this might be Mitch
McConnell ruining the chances in Georgia of
the Republican candidates by acknowledging
that Joe Biden won.
And so if Mitch McConnell wants to wake up
on January six.
And.
Be met with two of his Senate candidates all
of a sudden trailing in Georgia.
Keep talking like this.
Go out of your way to use the term congratulate.
If he had to and was getting pressure, he
could have at the very most today, I will
recognize I probably would have taken exception
with that.
But the term congratulations.
Inherently means that you are applauding and
recognizing in achievement of success.
When do you use congratulations in your life?
When people attain athletic.
Accomplishments when people get married, engaged.
You typically don't use the term congratulations
when someone just stole a bank.
I love that Charlie going full on.
He's Charlie doesn't even stop at robbing
a bank.
He says it's like stealing the entire bank,
just picking up the whole bank and taking
a really fascinating stuff.
So this is a similar situation to some trumpet's
who now think Fox News is liberal.
And part of the problem, the idea that someone
is wretchedly conservative as Mitch McConnell
might not be a strong enough right winger
just shows you how extreme the Trump cult
has become.
But understand that part of this is calculation
by Mitch.
Mitch knows they don't have the votes to actually
stop Joe Biden from being president.
They he knows they can't do anything.
And Mitch McConnell wants to get back to the
standard partizan bickering and Republican
obstruction of Democrats as soon as possible.
And so what Mitch McConnell is effectively
doing here is kind of ripping the Band-Aid
off now and getting people back to reality
sooner, get Republicans back to being united
about, you know, the deficit and stopping
anything Democrats want to do.
So I actually looking at it from the standpoint
of Mitch McConnell.
I think what he's doing here actually makes
perfect sense, it obviously makes sense based
on the votes Biden won and we knew that five
weeks ago.
But I think it also even is the right strategy
if your goal is to reunite the Republican
Party.
And let's get back to stopping Joe Biden from
doing a damn thing and they may well succeed
at it.